Katrina: 这是谁啊
Katrina: Who is this?
Shure: 啊看我笑的多灿烂啊
Shure: Ah, look how brightly I’m smiling.
Shure: 啊我又暗淡了
Shure: Ah, I’ve dimmed again.
Shure: 老板知道为什么我暗淡了吗
Shure: Boss, do you know why I’ve dimmed?
Jack: 因为没给钱是吧
Jack: Because you didn’t get paid, right?
Shure: 因为我想涨工资
Shure: Because I want a raise.
Jack: 啊
Jack: Ah.
Shure: 可以了可以了可以了
Shure: Alright, alright, alright.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 慢点慢点慢点慢点慢点
Katrina: Slow down, slow down, slow down, slow down, slow down.
Jake:准时
Jake: On time.
Shure: 懂懂
Shure: Understood.
Shure: 这叫什么
Shure: What’s this called?
Shure: 音乐脱口秀
Shure: Music talk show.
Shure: 懂了吧
Shure: Got it?
Jake: 可以
Jake: Yes.
Alice:你这状态持续多久了
Alice: How long have you been in this state?
Jack: 这是有有病
Jack: This is some kind of illness.
Jack: 有病得治
Jack: Illness needs treatment.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Katrina: 你弹的够悲伤的
Katrina: You're playing quite sadly.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Nicous: 妈的 跟着修硕这节奏
Nicous: Damn, following Shure's rhythm.
Shure: 有一种
Shure: There's a kind of...
Tasha:哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Shure: 怎么我的诗朗诵不好吗
Shure: Isn't my poetry recitation good?
Katrina: 特别好都想哭了
Katrina: It's so good, it makes you want to cry.
Jack: 太好了
Jack: It's great.
男嘉宾:关了
Male Guest: Turn it off.
Shure: 我都不知道难忘今宵的歌词是啥
Shure: I don't even know the lyrics of "Unforgettable Tonight".
Jake:就就这个
Jake: It's just this.
Shure: 难忘今宵
Shure: Unforgettable tonight.
Shure: 我们大家一起大合唱
Shure: Let's all sing together.
Jack: 我们来点年头小点的吧
Jack: Let's pick something a bit newer.
Shure: 年头小点的歌
Shure: A bit newer songs.
Shure: 怎么你你哈哈哈
Shure: Why are you, you, haha.
Jack: 哎这个可以可以
Jack: Hey, this one is good, good.
Jake:难忘哈哈哈
Jake: Unforgettable, haha.
Alice:你把凳子搬过来呗
Alice: Can you move the chair over here?
Katrina: 他改精神攻击了
Katrina: He's using psychological attacks now.
Jack: 你就会这一句是吧
Jack: You only know this one line, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Jake:不行了不行
Jake: I can't take it anymore.
Jake:你还要加工资
Jake: You still want a raise?
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Jake:你还要加工资
Jake: You still want a raise?
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
Jack: 这应该 是给人精神损失费是吧
Shure: 大家有有什么想听的歌吗
Shure: Does anyone have any song requests?
Shure: XBZ都会弹
Shure: XBZ can play anything.
Nicous: 我会库吗
Nicous: I can play, right?
Nicous: 哎呀这终于恢复正常了
Nicous: Ah, finally back to normal.
Nicous: 来来来找个什么歌唱什么
Nicous: Come on, let's pick a song to sing.
Shure: 唱什么
Shure: What to sing?
Shure: 你刚才说什么
Shure: What did you just say?
Shure: 不会
Shure: No way.
Jack: 看起来可以唱
Jack: Looks like you can sing.
女嘉宾:真的很会唱啊
Female Guest: You really can sing!
Jack: 能唱就唱
Jack: If you can sing, then sing.
Shure: 给大家表演一个
Shure: Perform for everyone.
Shure: 每次都会在酒后给大家表演的
Shure: Every time, after a few drinks, you always perform for us.
Shure: 叫什么来着哈哈
Shure: What’s it called again, haha?
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Alice:本人不伤心
Alice: I'm not sad.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Alice:试这个点心
Alice: Try this snack.
Shure: 就四个和弦
Shure: It's just four chords.
Shure: 你往低了点弹不就得了吗
Shure: Just play it a bit lower, won't you?
Shure: 哎呀我都能
Shure: Oh, even I can do it.
Shure: 弹到哪了
Shure: Where did you get to?
Shure: 就1645四个和弦
Shure: It's just 1645, four chords.
Shure: 我我我我我怎么怎么起的啊
Shure: I, I, I, I, how do I start?
Shure: 哎怎么怎么卧槽
Shure: Oh, how, how, what the hell?
Jack: 我又寡言掉了你懂个叫我行不
Jack: I got all quiet again, can you call me?
Shure: 我我我我最啊我最爱
Shure: I, I, I, I love, I love...
Shure: 卧哎卧槽
Shure: Oh, oh, damn.
Shure: 哈哈哈等一下
Shure: Hahaha, wait a sec.
Alice:气急败坏
Alice: So frustrated.
Shure: 啊啊啊找到了
Shure: Ah, ah, ah, found it!
Shure: 谢谢大家谢谢大家
Shure: Thank you, everyone, thank you.
Alice:你喝酒不喝
Alice: Are you drinking?
Alice:我给你拿杯子
Alice: I'll get you a cup.
Shure: 好了我们的egoKTV
Shure: Okay, our egoKTV.
Nicous: 下一首
Nicous: Next song.
Jake: 下一首
Jake: Next song.
Shure: 别下一首了哈哈哈
Shure: No more songs, haha.
Shure: 一会老底都揭没了怎么办
Shure: What if all my secrets get exposed?
Jack: 下一首
Jack: Next song.
Shure: 哎大家大家
Shure: Hey, everyone.
Alice:露西
Alice: Lucia.
Shure: 还会唱什么
Shure: What else can you sing?
Alice:过来点
Alice: Come closer.
Shure: 还听过什么
Shure: What else have you heard?
Shure: 就是能大家一起调动氛围一起唱的
Shure: It's like everyone can join in and sing together.
Lucia:想你了
Lucia: I miss you.
Shure: 想你了
Shure: I miss you too.
Lucia:哦不不不
Lucia: Oh no no no.
Shure: 想谁了哈哈哈
Shure: Who do you miss? Haha.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Lucia:人家想我了哈哈
Lucia: Someone misses me, haha.
Shure: 哎呀想想想想
Shure: Oh yes, they do, they do.
Shure: 别普通朋友了哈哈
Shure: Let's not just be ordinary friends, haha.
Shure: 老老在这唱这多晦气是吧哈哈
Shure: Singing this is such bad luck, right? Haha.
Shure: 什么东西
Shure: What's this?
Shure: 你这什么风格
Shure: What style is this?
Jack: 你今天弹这个
Jack: You're playing this today?
Jack: 应该有很多什么情歌之类的
Jack: There should be a lot of love songs and such.
Jack: 就流沙嘛
Jack: Like quicksand.
Jack: 爱情好像流沙
Jack: Love is like quicksand.
Jack: 不复挣扎嘛
Jack: No more struggling.
Lucia:出现
Lucia: Appear.
Shure: 我这就
Shure: I'm just...
Lucia:你今天晚上住这边吗
Lucia: Are you staying here tonight?
Shure: 主要已经脱离了那个唱苦情歌的阶段
Shure: Mainly, I've moved past the stage of singing sad love songs.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
男嘉宾:有了对像了是吧
Male Guest: You have someone now, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 那你唱那个
Katrina: Then sing that one.
Jack: 那那那来点甜甜的吧
Jack: Then, then, let's have something sweet.
Katrina: 你唱那个
Katrina: Sing that one.
Katrina: 恋爱ING吧反正你也是恋爱ING
Katrina: Sing "In Love", since you are in love.
Shure: 恋爱ING的词是什么来着
Shure: What are the lyrics to "In Love"?
Shure: 那那有点唱不上去
Shure: That one is a bit hard to sing.
男嘉宾:情非得已
Male Guest: "Unwilling Love".
Alice:咋啦
Alice: What's up?
刘婷:快跟人亲热亲热快点
Liu Ting: Hurry up and get close, come on.
Katrina: 情非得已也行
Katrina: "Unwilling Love" works too.
男嘉宾:有何不可
Male Guest: Why not?
Katrina: 唱素颜吧
Katrina: Sing "Bareface".
Alice:我鞋呢
Alice: Where are my shoes?
Katrina: 对着你女朋友唱素颜
Katrina: Sing "Bareface" to your girlfriend.
Jake:哎唱素颜了
Jake: Hey, sing "Bareface".
Alice:我这人不爱穿鞋有什么毛病
Alice: I just don't like wearing shoes, is that a problem?
Katrina: 你女朋友给你唱那个
Katrina: Your girlfriend sang that for you
Katrina: 她唱女生不
Katrina: Did she sing female parts?
男嘉宾:来点那什么小小那个
Male Guest: How about a little bit of that...
Alice:我又不脚臭
Alice: I don't have smelly feet
Shure: 来嘛
Shure: Come on
Katrina: 素颜嘛
Katrina: No makeup, right?
Shure: 唱一个素颜来了
Shure: Sing a no-makeup song
Shure: 素颜来了
Shure: No makeup song
Katrina: 来嘛
Katrina: Come on
Shure的女友:等会我再喝口
Shure's GF: Wait a minute, let me drink first
Alice:我去给他拿杯子
Alice: I'll get him a cup
Shure: 行
Shure: Alright
叉叉:素颜 素颜
Jack: No makeup, no makeup
Shure: 来给我给我也整一杯
Shure: Get me a cup too
Alice:哎哟
Alice: Oh my
Shure的女友:还有杯子吗
Shure's GF: Are there any more cups?
Alice:来我给你洗一个
Alice: I'll wash one for you
Alice:哎没了我靠
Alice: Ah, we're out, damn
刘婷:用碗也行
Liu Ting: A bowl works too
Alice:好那我就碗了啊
Alice: Okay, I'll use a bowl then
Shure的女友:这没杯子了吗
Shure's GF: Are there no more cups?
Alice:这没了
Alice: We're out
Shure: 你能可以只弹左手
Shure: Can you play with just your left hand?
Shure: 刘帅要不你替我弹
Shure: Choiszt, can you play for me?
Choiszt: 我没听过你弹这个
Choiszt: I've never heard you play this
Shure: 你弹弹就行
Shure: Just play it
Katrina: 你没听过这歌
Katrina: You've never heard this song?
Shure: 哎OK OK
Shure: Hey, OK, OK
男嘉宾:喂 喂
Male Guest: Hello, hello
Alice:给
Alice: Here
Alice:擦过了哈哈哈
Alice: I wiped it, hahaha
Alice:不用这么客气
Alice: No need to be so polite
Shure: 怎么还整俩碗呢
Shure: Why are there two bowls?
Shure: 结拜了是吗
Shure: Are we becoming sworn brothers?
Katrina: 哎这是啥意思
Katrina: Hey, what does this mean?
Alice:让我过去
Alice: Let me pass
Shure: 我要那 就要 还没
Shure: I want that, just that, not yet
Alice:你要吗露西哦你不能喝哦
Alice: Do you want it, Lucia? Oh, you can't drink
Lucia:我不喝
Lucia: I don't drink
Alice:刘婷你喝不喝
Alice: Liu Ting, do you drink?
Alice:你别喝了
Alice: Stop drinking.
Alice:小孩不让喝酒
Alice: Kids aren't allowed to drink alcohol.
Lucia:这不是饮料这是水
Lucia: This isn't a drink, it's water.
Shure: 可以可以哇哈哈哈
Shure: Alright, alright, hahaha.
男嘉宾:用碗
Male Guest: Use a bowl.
Shure: 你说啥
Shure: What did you say?
Alice:没杯子
Alice: No cups.
Lucia:微醺
Lucia: Tipsy.
Shure: 纯饮一碗是吧
Shure: Just drink a bowl, right?
Katrina: 农夫山泉微醺水
Katrina: Nongfu Spring Tipsy Water.
Jack: 可以可以
Jack: Alright, alright.
Shure: 随便随便
Shure: Whatever, whatever.
Katrina: 行你两个小时确实有点
Katrina: Okay, two hours is indeed a bit much.
Alice:你喝吗 哦你不喝
Alice: Are you drinking? Oh, you're not.
Alice:我今晚怎么回事
Alice: What's going on with me tonight?
Lucia:一顿乱回
Lucia: Completely messed up.
Jack: 可以啊 厉害呀
Jack: Impressive, really.
Jake:手挺狠啊
Jake: You're quite bold.
Jack: 要喝好啊
Jack: Want to drink? Go ahead.
Alice:紫棠你要吗
Alice: Violet, do you want some?
Katrina: 拜拜拜拜
Katrina: Bye, bye.
Alice:我下去给你找个杯子啥的
Alice: I'll go find a cup for you.
Shure: 哎呀不好
Shure: Oh no, this isn't good.
Alice:你不要吗
Alice: You don't want it?
Katrina: 那我把他送到门口吧走吧
Katrina: I'll see him to the door. Let's go.
Alice:你要吗你要吗
Alice: Do you want it? Do you want it?
Alice:我给你找个容器
Alice: I'll find you a container.
Katrina: 你知咋出去不虽然我自已也不在
Katrina: You know how to get out, right? Though I'm not sure myself.
Katrina: 虽然我自己也不在
Katrina: Though I'm not sure myself.
Katrina: 迷宫啊
Katrina: It's a maze.
Katrina: 这一片我第一次出来时候也绕半天
Katrina: The first time I came out here, I wandered around for ages too.
Katrina: 这咋了 哈哈哈哈 咋了
Katrina: What's up? Hahaha, what's up?
Katrina: 要不要再带一个小蛋糕走
Katrina: Want to take another small cake?
Alice:杯子呢
Alice: Where are the cups?
Katrina: 确实
Katrina: Indeed.
Alice:还有小蛋糕呢
Alice: There's still some cake.
Katrina: 我吃不下了 等会再吃吧
Katrina: I can't eat anymore, I'll have it later.
Katrina: 我等一会吃吧
Katrina: I'll have it later.
Alice:你的朋友要走了吗
Alice: Is your friend leaving?
Katrina: 对她回去两个小时
Katrina: Yeah, she's heading back, it'll take two hours.
Alice:我来洗吧
Alice: Let me wash it.
Alice:但是这要一次性的
Alice: But this one is disposable.
Lucia:不能用一次性的
Lucia: We can't use disposables.
Alice:要玻璃杯
Alice: We need glass cups.
Katrina: 今天是世界地球日
Katrina: Today is Earth Day.
Alice:对不起对对对对不起
Alice: Sorry, sorry, sorry, my bad.
Alice:我有罪
Alice: My fault.
Alice:我来洗吧
Alice: Let me wash it.
Katrina: 噢 今天周几啊
Katrina: Oh, what day is it today?
Katrina: 他们上来找杯子
Katrina: They came up looking for cups.
Katrina: 拜拜
Katrina: Bye-bye.
Katrina: 我想想一般是走哪啊
Katrina: Let me think, which way to go usually?
Katrina: 呃
Katrina: Uh...
Katrina: 走这边那个
Katrina: Go this way.
Katrina: 走这边有一个右拐有个咖啡店
Katrina: Go this way, then take a right, there's a coffee shop.
Katrina: 你看到咖啡店就比较好出去了拜拜拜拜
Katrina: When you see the coffee shop, it's easier to find your way out. Bye-bye, bye-bye.
Katrina: 拜拜拜拜
Katrina: Bye-bye, bye-bye.
Katrina: 好的
Katrina: Okay.
Shure: 无可估量
Shure: Immeasurable.
Shure: 我开始学老板反向画饼哈哈哈
Shure: I'm starting to learn from the boss to draw the opposite picture, haha.
Jake:太 确实
Jake: Yeah, indeed.
Shure: 来吧你给我倒回去吧
Shure: Come on, pour it back for me.
Shure: 放这吧放这吧
Shure: Put it here, put it here.
Shure: 我倒回去
Shure: I'll pour it back.
Alice:给你拿巧克力
Alice: I'll get you some chocolate.
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Jake:就朝着弱智吧那路去了
Jake: Just heading down the path of stupidity.
Alice:恩将仇报是吧
Alice: Repaying kindness with ingratitude, right?
Shure: 我们我们
Shure: We, we...
Shure: 这个是人类
Shure: This is humanity.
Shure: 其实是一些正常的活动
Shure: These are actually normal activities.
Jake:哎正常活动
Jake: Yeah, normal activities.
Jake:都很正常
Jake: All very normal.
Shure: 不不不造作
Shure: Not pretentious.
Jake:就 就你不喝酒就唱不上去
Jake: Yeah, you can't sing well if you don't drink.
Jake:这很的
Jake: That's true.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Jake:对 这个就
Jake: Yeah, this...
Shure: AI根本想不到这点对吧
Shure: AI would never think of this, right?
Shure: 能啊
Shure: It can.
Jack: 你错过了
Jack: You missed it.
Jake:再来一次
Jake: Let's do it again.
Jack: 精彩发言
Jack: Great speech.
男嘉宾:你说高不高呢
Male Guest: Do you think it's high or not?
Jack: 这样
Jack: Like this.
Jack: 这你 你先说
Jack: You, you go first.
Jack: 你说高不高吧
Jack: Do you think it's high or not?
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 哎我靠
Shure: Oh, damn.
Shure: 来吧女嘉宾
Shure: Come on, female guest.
Alice:吃提拉米苏不吃
Alice: Do you want Tiramisu or not?
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
男嘉宾:刚刚喝酒干嘛呢
Male Guest: What were you doing just drinking?
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
男嘉宾:你已经忘了喝酒干嘛了
Male Guest: You already forgot why you were drinking?
Jake:呵呵看来喝挺多
Jake: Haha, seems like you drank a lot.
男嘉宾:已经倒半天了
Male Guest: It's been pouring for a long time.
Alice:别玩抽象
Alice: Don't play abstract.
Shure: 词写上了
Shure: The words are written.
Jake:有 有词有词
Jake: Yes, yes, the words are there.
Shure: 呃你稍微放大一点
Shure: Uh, can you enlarge it a bit?
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh.
Shure: 刘帅好OK
Shure: Choiszt, good, okay.
Shure: 然后你来翻谱对OK
Shure: Then you turn the score, okay?
Jake:我 我来给你播
Shure: 这回能看清了吧
Shure: Can you see it clearly now?
Shure: 我
Shure: I...
男嘉宾:倒酒
Male Guest: Pour the wine.
Shure: 来吧来吧拿 过来
Shure: Come on, come on, bring it over.
Alice:我给你拿个勺子类的东西
Alice: I'll get you something like a spoon.
Shure: 来吧准备
Shure: Come on, get ready.
Shure: 可以了
Shure: It's ready.
Alice:你修修图啊稍等我
Alice: Are you editing the picture? Wait for me.
Shure:  一段就可以了
Shure: One segment is enough.
Jack: 你有没有拍下去呢
Jack: Did you take the shot?
男嘉宾:刚刚发生了什么
Male Guest: What just happened?
Jake:啊没看见
Jake: Ah, didn't see it.
Alice:什么什么什么
Alice: What, what, what?
Alice:波啦
Alice: Oh, no.
Jake:OK OK没关系这边有个机会
Jake: OK, OK, no worries, there's another chance here.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh no
Katrina: 我今天晚上受不了了
Katrina: I can't take it anymore tonight
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Katrina: 啊真难受
Katrina: Ah, it's really unbearable
Katrina: 点一首唯一
Katrina: Play the song "The Only One"
Alice:在来一块
Alice: Have another piece
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on
Nicous: 小黄 唱吧
Nicous: Nicous, sing it
Katrina: E了
Katrina: I'm done
Shure: 您来唱
Shure: You sing
Katrina: 真E了
Katrina: Really done
男嘉宾:咱心里
Male Guest: In our hearts
男嘉宾:也是难以
Male Guest: It's also hard
Tasha:也是男女
Tasha: It's also between men and women
Shure: 我不会
Shure: I don't know it
Shure的女友:那首我真不会
Shure's GF: I really don't know that song
Shure的女友:这首还唱过
Shure's GF: But I've sung this one
Shure的女友:那首真不会
Shure's GF: I really don't know that one
男嘉宾:OK
Male Guest: OK
男嘉宾:告五人的是不是王力宏的
Male Guest: Is it by Accusefive or Wang Leehom
Shure: 对 告5人的
Shure: Yes, it's by Accusefive
Shure: 告五人的
Shure: It's by Accusefive
Shure: 告5人的
Shure: 告五人你弹的是王力宏的
Shure: You played the one by Wang Leehom
Shure: 你谈的是王力宏的啊
Shure: You played the one by Wang Leehom, huh
男嘉宾:这是告五人的吗
Male Guest: Is this by Accusefive
Jack: 啊告五人
Jack: Ah, it's by Accusefive
Jack: 这这这跟那个有什么区别吗
Jack: Is there any difference between them
Nicous: 是两个两个
Nicous: They're two different songs
Shure: 完全不一样的歌
Shure: Completely different songs
Nicous: 完全不一样
Nicous: Completely different
Shure: 两种不一样
Shure: Two different ones
Jack: 哦
Jack: Oh
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on
Katrina: 我真的能唱吗
Katrina: Can I really sing it
Shure: 你可以的
Shure: You can do it
Katrina: 来
Katrina: Let's go
Shure: 你不行少和弦就行
Shure: If you can't, just play fewer chords
Katrina: 你帮我合着点
Katrina: Help me out a bit
Shure: 我还帮你合着点
Shure: I'll help you out a bit
Katrina: 就大家帮我合着点
Katrina: Everyone, help me out a bit.
Katrina: 我一个人唱我的声音我会觉得很尴尬
Katrina: I feel really awkward singing alone.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 我看从哪开始
Katrina: Let me see where to start.
Katrina: 我靠挺好我不知道从哪进
Katrina: Oh man, I don't know where to jump in.
Alice:吃提拉米苏吗我给你切一块
Alice: Want some tiramisu? I'll cut you a piece.
Katrina: 你能提示一下吗
Katrina: Can you give me a hint?
Lucia:我下午吃了
Lucia: I had some this afternoon.
Alice:他说挺好吃的
Alice: He said it's really good.
Lucia:对我也觉得挺好吃的
Lucia: Yeah, I think it's pretty good too.
Lucia:是吧
Lucia: Right?
Katrina: 我也觉得
Katrina: I agree.
Alice:吃提拉米苏吗我给你切一块
Alice: Want some tiramisu? I'll cut you a piece.
Shure: 哎我直接弹了得了
Shure: Hey, let me just play it.
Shure: 来吧来吧
Shure: Come on, let's go.
Shure的女友:我吃过了
Shure's GF: I already had some.
Alice:你要吗
Alice: Do you want some?
Lucia:我们俩一起吃的
Lucia: We had it together.
Shure: 你这怎么D调你知道吗
Shure: Do you know how to change this to D major?
Alice:你要吗给你切一下
Alice: Do you want some? I'll cut you a piece.
男嘉宾:我从来不用这些
Male Guest: I never use these.
Alice:我得给你找个容器
Alice: Let me find you a container.
Shure: 我草
Shure: Damn it.
Shure: 你给我移个调我就可以可以
Shure: If you change the key for me, I can play it.
Alice:给你用这个吧
Alice: Use this one then.
Katrina: 这是在干什么呢
Katrina: What are you guys doing?
Alice:你在乱叫
Alice: You're just yelling.
Alice:妈的我杀了你
Shure: 等一下啊
Shure: Wait a second.
Shure: 我稍等我稍微移个调就可以
Shure: Hold on, let me just change the key a bit.
Shure: 你怎么移调啊
Shure: How do you change the key?
男嘉宾:这歌你没听过吗
Male Guest: Haven't you heard this song?
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Katrina: 没听过吗
Katrina: Haven't you heard it?
Nicous: 哦这这这这这个
Nicous: Oh, this, this, this...
Jake:这两天来少了
Jake: Haven't been here much these days.
男嘉宾:不会每天都唱吧
Male Guest: Don't sing every day, right?
Katrina: 每天都唱这首歌一到晚上
Katrina: Sing this song every night.
Jake:每天都唱
Jake: Sing every day.
Shure: 要不这个我帮你弹
Shure: How about I play it for you?
男嘉宾:啊
Male Guest: Ah
Jack: 哦
Jack: Oh
Shure: 你这调对吗你想想
Shure: Is your pitch right? Think about it.
Alice:露西亚让我过一下下
Alice: Lucia, let me pass for a sec.
Lucia:啊好的
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Alice:哎我看有点
Alice: Hey, I think it's a bit...
Lucia:这个呃是不是还要在
Lucia: This, um, do we need to...
Alice:噢噢谢谢
Alice: Oh, oh, thanks.
Lucia:没事
Lucia: No problem.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Jake:谢彬竹没搞定
Jake: Xie Binzhu didn't get it done.
Shure: 你就全程在这翻手机
Shure: You've been on your phone the whole time.
Shure: 你在你在后面有什么用
Shure: What's the point of you being in the back?
Shure: 四级
Shure: Level four.
Shure: 然后你往上移半个调不就得了吗
Shure: Then just move up half a pitch, right?
Shure: 笨死了可
Shure: So dumb, seriously.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey
Katrina: 从头吗
Katrina: From the start?
Jack: 从头吧
Jack: From the start then.
Shure: OK能不能找到了哥
Shure: Okay, can you find it this time, bro?
Shure: 这次
Shure: This time...
Shure: 这这次
Shure: This... this time...
Shure: 那我就给你声开大点了啊
Shure: I'll turn up the volume for you, alright?
Alice:要哪个
Alice: Which one?
Shure: 真没有问题了
Shure: No more problems now.
Shure: 哈哈哈哎
Shure: Hahaha, hey.
Nicous: 准备
Nicous: Ready.
Jake:你又行了了是吧
Jake: Are you good again?
Shure: 他又行了
Shure: He's good again.
Alice:行
Alice: Alright.
Shure: 能不能找到他哥
Shure: Can you find him, bro?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Shure: 那刚才不是完事了吗
Shure: Didn't we just finish?
Alice:能给我发个消息吗找不着你了
Alice: Can you send me a message? I can't find you.
Shure: 好终于对上了
Shure: Okay, finally got it right.
Alice:太卡了
Alice: It's so laggy.
Shure: 你在你在后面有什么用
Shure: What's the point of you being in the back?
Katrina: 来
Katrina: Come on.
Alice:搜不到
Alice: Can't find it.
Jake:你真的懂
Jake: Do you really understand?
Jake:呀
Jake: Ah
Katrina: OK哦
Katrina: OK
Katrina: 换下一首
Katrina: Next song
Shure: 还有要表演的同学
Shure: Anyone else wants to perform?
男嘉宾:靖康
Male Guest: Jingkang
Shure: 靖康你会唱什么
Shure: Jingkang, what can you sing?
Katrina: 唱一首
Katrina: Sing a song
Shure: 这老板得唱一首吧
Shure: The boss has to sing a song, right?
Shure: 唱什么老板啊
Shure: What will the boss sing?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
男嘉宾:你会唱什么
Male Guest: What can you sing?
Katrina: 爱拼才会赢
Katrina: "Love to Win"
Jake:行来
Jake: Sure, let's go
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Shure: 老板真会唱吗
Shure: Can the boss really sing?
Jake:不会
Jake: No
Shure: 老板会会
Shure: The boss can, can
Shure: 会唱点什么吗
Shure: Can you sing something?
Alice:yes OK
Alice: Yes, OK
女嘉宾:are you OK
Female Guest: Are you OK?
Jake:are you OK
Jake: Are you OK?
Alice:他的手机铃声
Alice: It's his phone ringtone
Jake:are you OK这个倒是可以
Jake: "Are you OK" could work
Shure: 哎呦
Shure: Oh dear
Lucia:婧康的手机铃声
Lucia: It's Jingkang's phone ringtone
Jake:are you OK
Jake: Are you OK
Shure: 那我
Shure: Then I...
Shure: 这怎么办呢
Shure: What should I do?
Shure: 这这大家以后你看
Shure: Look, everyone, from now on...
Shure: 这就是一个情商小课堂
Shure: This is an emotional intelligence class
男嘉宾:富士山下
Male Guest: Under Mount Fuji
男嘉宾:哦
Male Guest: Oh
Jack: 可以可以
Jack: Alright, alright
Alice:我现在就去山东进修
Alice: I’m going to Shandong for further studies now
Shure: 可以
Alice:呃山东
Alice: Uh, Shandong
Alice:呃哈哈哈哈
Alice: Uh, hahaha
Alice:情商小课堂
Alice: Emotional intelligence class
Shure: are you OK哈喽
Shure: Are you OK, hello?
Lucia:我靠
Lucia: Oh my god
Shure: 老板来
Shure: Boss, come here.
Shure: 我觉得这样也可以
Shure: I think this works too.
Shure: 咱们也不尴尬
Shure: It's not awkward for us.
Jake:用不着用不着
Jake: No need, no need.
Jake:用不着
Jake: No need.
Jake:用不着用不着
Jake: No need, no need.
Shure: 要成功哈哈哈
Shure: We need to succeed, haha.
Jake:先打
Jake: Let's start first.
Lucia:不是谁是老板啊
Lucia: Who's the boss, though?
Shure: 老板老板
Shure: Boss, boss.
Jake:用不着
Jake: No need.
Jake:用不着用不着
Jake: No need, no need.
Jake:呃算了
Jake: Uh, never mind.
Jake:哈哈挺会
Jake: Haha, pretty good.
Katrina: 这弹啥了
Katrina: What's being played?
Shure: 他把老板的歌词给弹了
Shure: He's playing the boss's song.
Shure: 这种一般都怎么处理呢
Shure: How do you usually deal with this?
Alice:送去山东
Alice: Send him to Shandong.
Jack: 不趁着人多的时候说话知道不
Jack: Don't talk when there are many people around, got it?
Shure: 我感觉这样
Shure: I feel like...
Shure: 明天他左脚就可能踏进公司了吧
Shure: Tomorrow, he might step into the company with his left foot.
Katrina: 那个唱富士山下
Katrina: The one singing "Under the Mount Fuji"?
Shure: 所以所以XBZ
Shure: So, so, XB...
Jack: 可以
Jack: Okay.
Shure: 你你在这里的
Shure: You, you here...
Katrina: 起一个什么作用呢
Katrina: What's your role here?
Shure: 气氛组
Shure: The atmosphere team.
Katrina: 起一个logo作用哈哈哈
Katrina: You play a logo role, haha.
Shure: logo怎么这牌子
Shure: Logo? This brand...
Shure: 打钱了是吗
Shure: Did they pay?
Katrina: 唱点经典的
Katrina: Sing some classics.
Katrina: 大家都会的
Katrina: Ones everyone knows.
Katrina: 周杰伦陈奕迅
Katrina: Jay Chou, Eason Chan.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Jack: 可不可以又弹又跳一条龙
Jack: Can you play and dance, like an all-in-one show?
男嘉宾:这有点难
Male Guest: That's a bit tough.
Katrina: 这个词有点难看到
Katrina: This word is a bit hard to see.
Katrina: 好吧好的
Katrina: Alright, okay.
男嘉宾:来一个来一个来一个
Male Guest: Come on, come on, come on.
Shure: 兑一起然后再分一半
Shure: Mix it together and then split it in half.
Katrina: 我给他录一个
Katrina: I'll record one for him.
Shure: 哇谢彬竹
Shure: Wow, thanks Binzhu.
Shure: 终于默契了一次
Shure: Finally, we synced up once.
Shure: 我懂了问题出在我身上
Shure: I get it now, the problem is on me.
Shure: 不是不是你身上
Shure: No, no, it's not on you.
Shure: 懂了懂了
Shure: Got it, got it.
Shure: 跟跟跟那个帅师傅比较
Shure: Compared to Master Shuai...
Shure: 比较投缘是吧
Shure: We hit it off better, right?
Nicous: 下一个
Nicous: Next.
Shure: 下一个
Shure: Next.
Nicous: 你来一个
Nicous: Your turn.
Jake:对你来一个
Jake: Yeah, your turn.
男嘉宾:不用啦
Male Guest: No need.
Shure: 我们有全民K歌
Shure: We have the KTV app.
Katrina: 实在不行普通朋友
Katrina: If it doesn't work, just be normal friends.
男嘉宾:普通朋友
Male Guest: Normal friends.
Katrina: 大家一起唱就没事
Katrina: If everyone sings together, it's fine.
Katrina: 来来来
Katrina: Come on, come on.
Katrina: RNB是非常适合这种氛围的
Katrina: R&B is really fitting for this vibe.
Katrina: 没关系挺可爱
Katrina: It's okay, quite cute.
Katrina: 没事
Katrina: No worries.
Shure的女友:都很喜欢
Shure's GF: Everyone likes it.
Jack: 给给给找个词呗
Jack: Give, give, give, find some lyrics.
男嘉宾:哦
Male Guest: Oh.
Shure: 发完了记得删
Shure: Remember to delete it after posting.
Shure: 别被你女朋友发现了
Shure: Don't let your girlfriend find out.
Shure: 你不是孤优从立
Shure: You're not a lone ranger.
Shure: 加入了最后一句
Shure: Added the last line.
Shure: 具有个人特色的rap部分
Shure: With my unique rap part.
Shure: 这谢彬竹每次最后一下叮一下就是哎
Shure: This Binzhu always nails the last note, like...
Shure: 非点睛一下
Shure: Can't miss that final touch.
Shure: 就是除了内我基本没听清哈哈哈
Shure: Apart from that, I barely heard anything, haha.
Nicous: 两条进不去啊没歌词
Nicous: Two lines won't fit, no lyrics.
Shure: 好该谁了
Shure: Okay, whose turn?
Shure: 到谁了
Shure: Who's up?
Katrina: 会弹的不就你们两个吗
Katrina: Aren't you two the ones who can play?
男嘉宾:对呀
Male Guest: Yeah.
Katrina: 点歌呗
Katrina: Pick a song.
Shure: 主要我我唱的
Shure: Mainly, I sing...
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes
Katrina: 你点个呗
Katrina: Can you click it?
Shure: 好别摘不下来
Shure: Alright, don't take it off.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
男嘉宾:好摘
Male Guest: Easy to take off.
Katrina: 前面怎么唱来着
Katrina: How did the front part go?
Shure: 摘不下来的时候
Shure: When you can't take it off.
Shure的女友:哎呀别别别别别
Shure's GF: Oh no, don't, don't, don't, don't!
Shure: 到时候跟我妈妈哭
Shure: Then you'll cry to my mom.
Shure: 妈妈你看
Shure: Mom, look.
Shure: 他把我这个戒指抢走还摘不下来
Shure: He took my ring and can't get it off.
Shure: 妈给他剁了哈
Shure: Mom, cut it off for him.
Shure的女友:我知道不能丢
Shure's GF: I know I can't lose it.
Shure的女友:这个丢了我真哭给你看
Shure's GF: If I lose this, I'll really cry for you.
Katrina: 受不了了
Katrina: I can't take it anymore.
Katrina: 这对小情侣
Katrina: This couple.
Katrina: 我怎么看不清词啊
Katrina: Why can't I see the lyrics clearly?
Katrina: 直接拍情侣写真了
Katrina: They're directly taking couple photos.
Katrina: 哎  哎哟什么时候我也有男朋友
Katrina: Oh, oh, when will I have a boyfriend?
Katrina: 拍一个哈哈哈
Katrina: To take a photo with, haha.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure的女友:就是我找那种
Shure's GF: It's just like I found that kind.
Shure的女友:我感觉大家都会唱的歌
Shure's GF: I feel like everyone can sing it.
Shure的女友:他说OK这一首我好像知道
Shure's GF: He said, OK, I think I know this one.
Katrina: 周杰伦还有什么歌
Katrina: What other songs does Jay Chou have?
Shure的女友:忘记了忘记了
Shure's GF: Forgot, forgot.
Shure: 东北人有自己的一套粤语体系
Shure: Northeasterners have their own Cantonese system.
Shure: 知道吗哈哈哈哈
Shure: You know that? Hahaha.
Shure的女友:不是啊戴瑞家山西的啊
Shure's GF: No, Dairui is from Shanxi.
女嘉宾:戴瑞是山西人
Female Guest: Dairui is from Shanxi.
Katrina: 这我也听过
Katrina: I've heard this too.
Katrina: 这不是高中的时候
Katrina: Isn't this from high school?
Violet: 对对对好火的
Violet: Yes, yes, it was so popular.
Katrina: 听的诗班淡淡的
Katrina: The choir's faint singing.
Katrina: 哈哈这首好适合吉他弹
Katrina: Haha, this song is perfect for guitar.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Alice:没事你喜欢的话你拿走也行
Alice: It's okay, if you like it, you can take it.
Shure的女友:啊就是拍卖的开辟
Shure's GF: Ah, it's just the opening of the auction.
Shure的女友:已经不属于他的买家了是吗
Shure's GF: It's no longer the buyer's.
Jack: 对呀
Jack: Yeah.
Alice:对
Alice: Right.
Lucia:对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Jack: 啊好过分啊
Jack: Ah, that's so mean.